[Music]
the return of Ooma loomas into your life
is only one of five great picks this
week but what more do you really need
along with a prequel to a childhood
classic about well chocolate we've got
the return of Percy Jackson now in
series form a very Bradley Cooper movie
A dramedy starring highly underrated
Jeffrey Wright and season two of one of
Prime's best shows and that's not a
reach it's all coming up on this week's
what to watch Mr won I can say you're a
man of great engineer what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like it dark white nutty absolutely
insane bringing the Oompa and the Loompa
to theaters is the musical fantasy film
Wonka the first reason to check this one
out is that it serves as a prequel to
The 1971 classic Wily Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory and features Wonka's
early days as an eccentric choler hey is
an eccentric choler going on tour next
spring another reason is that this film
stars Timothy shalam who was director
Paul King's only choice after seeing
shalom's High School singing and dancing
performances on YouTube he's joined by a
Supporting Cast that includes Olivia
Coleman Keegan Michael Key and Hugh
Grant as wait for it and Oompa Loompa
thirdly director King is actually well
suited for this gig considering he has
the familyfriendly Paddington and
Paddington 2 on his resume the latter of
which was the best reviewed movie on
Rotten Tomatoes ever for a Time by the
way Paddington 2 is one of the best
movies ever made we will fight you if we
have to Percy the stories I have told
you of about great Gods and
Monsters they are real premiering on
Disney plus this week is the new series
Percy Jackson and the Olympians the main
reason to give this show a chance is
that it comes from a series of very
popular fantasy novels first published
in 2005 with a six installment that came
this year and another one coming in 2024
there's also two prequel book series and
some other related short stories as well
so if this new show is popular you know
there's more where that came from of
course you may remember the Percy
Jackson movies that came in 2010 and
2013 starring Logan lurman and Alexandre
Daario which are both rotten on the
Tomato Meter mostly due to deviations
from The Source material but unlike
those movies this series will have the
book's author Rick Riordan heavily
involved to make sure things stay true
to his work the third reason to watch
this show is the cast which is a mix of
newbies led by Walker scoel as Percy and
Veterans like Megan malali Lyn Manuel
Miranda and the late Lance reic in his
final TV appearance rip I love people so
much that did
it's hard for me to be
alone that music it keeps me glued to
life Chris Shen doing its way into
Netflix this week is the biopic Maestro
and perhaps the main reason to
orchestrate way to see this is that it's
based on an American composer Leonard
Bernstein and his relationship with wife
Felicia Monte algra so you'll learn a
thing or two of course the lens of
Hollywood that is a second big reason to
watch Maestro is Bradley Cooper sure he
stars in it as Bernstein but he also
directed The the movie and co-wrote it
with Josh singer who by the way won an
Oscar for writing Spotlight call that
reason 2.1 the cast also includes Carrie
Mulligan as Monty algra plus Matt Bomer
Maya Hawk she's related to Ethan by the
way and Sarah Silverman the third reason
to take the time to enjoy this film is
that after premiering in the Venice film
festival in September it's already very
certified fresh with a high audience
score to go with it it's like when the
brass and the woodwinds blend perfectly
together or something monk your books
are good but they're not popular editors
they want a black book they have a black
book I'm black and it's my book opening
in theaters this week is the dram film
American fiction the first thing that
jumps out with this one is the equally
fun and thought-provoking story about a
frustrated black novelist who jokingly
writes an overly stereotypical black
book out of spite that unexpectedly
becomes a hit secondly the cast is
stacked led by Jeffrey Wright in the
lead role and folks like Tracy Ellis
Ross Isa Ray and Sterling K Brown also
along from the ride so good third reason
you'll want to stay true to seeing
American fiction is that it's already a
certified fresh hit with critics with
much praise going to WR and his quote
committed approach to the pointedly
humorous and insightful material they
were tortured they dumped them from a
helicopter and they're coming after
us good and coming back for a highly
anticipated second season is the prime
show Reacher this series made a huge
Splash when it debuted in 2022 becoming
the first Amazon production to be quote
most stream series for its first week
according to the neelen streaming
rankings not to mention it's certified
fresh with critics if that's not reason
enough to reach for the remote it's
worth noting that this show is of course
based on the popular series by Lee Child
which began back in 1997 and is still
going strong today reading is good and
speaking of the book series the third
reason to check this one out is the
show's star Alan richson who fits the
book's profile of Jack Breer perfectly
and much more so than the movies did
meaning richson is big and bulky and Tom
Cruz well isn't either of those things
still love you Tom all right we did it
five picks that seriously all look
really good I don't know how else to say
it be sure to let us and your fellow
viewers know in the comments what you
did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out Ron
tomatoes.com for the latest updates on
scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay
freshh